An Australian teenager
has filed a lawsuit
against several publications
thanks to this image.
The lawsuit claims that ever
since this photo's publication,
the plaintiff has been
relentlessly memed
because
of his luxuriant haircut.
That's all business
in the front, party in the back,
Staten Island garbage man
on top,
and medieval monk with leukemia
on the sides.
-(cheers and applause)
-Uh...
♪ Leukemia monk.
The lawsuit specifically
mentions this image,
of someone trying
to pin the mullet on the donkey.
(laughter)
(cheers and applause)
But I have to say,
this one's my favorite.
This is where he looks like...
(laughter, applause)
This...
This looks like he's about to DJ
a dubstep rave at the Alamo.
(laughter)
But one of the defendants
fired back, quote,
"By reason
of his mullet hairstyle,
the plaintiff has justifiably
exposed himself to ridicule,"
and, quote, "The plaintiff
is a ridiculous person."
-(laughter)
-Uh... either way...
Sustained.
I'll allow it.
Either way, this landmark case
could open the floodgates
for other memes to sue,
so, comedians, what's another
Internet celebrity
who might seek legal recourse,
and what are they suing for?
Nico.
That cop is suing for what those
two awful girls did to him.
-Yeah, all right, points.
-(laughter, applause)
Yeah. Colton.
The "Chocolate Rain" guy is
suing the Weather Channel
for classifying "Chocolate Rain"
as climate change.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
Points. -(laughter, applause)
-Lauren. -Grumpy Cat is gonna
sue for defamation,
because that cat is not grumpy.
She's just got
resting bitch face.
HARDWICK:
Yeah. Points.
-(applause and cheering)
-Points. She really does.
She really does.